michael chandler and uh dan hooker might
be on that card with you guys i saw that
dude that's a great fight
and uh uh a good test for chandler to
see where he's at in the pecking order
of the lightweight division because
he'll toss him in the top end
which he should be man you know he's one
of the best 150 fighters out there
he's he's definitely i mean he's a hard
worker i mean he's you know he's done
obviously a wonderful and bellator
he's he's a really nice guy dude i've
met him
um he actually went out of his way to
come shake my hand he said
introduce himself and i was like man
this is this seems like a really
straight shooter a really good guy
man he's a nice dude and he works so
hard uh
i mean all you guys do especially at
your level i mean it's your full-time
job yeah what do you think about that
fight i mean you haven't fought in
chandler but you've gotten a fight
hooker
do you have any thoughts on that fight i
um it'll be
i think it'll come down to i think uh
hooker beats him on the feet
i i do and uh i think the length you
know chandler's not a tall guy
hooker's really long and a better boxer
than i thought he was
good timing uh tough to get his rhythm
he
easy hooker's a tough fight for anybody
i think it'll be if chandler can get the
takedowns
and if he does can he keep him down i
think it's it's gonna be a 15 minute
fight if it's on the same card as us
so he might you know if he starts
getting takedowns and getting dominant
position he might be able to win a
decision
i'm not saying he can't finish hooker he
can finish him but
i would lean towards hooker on that one
man
yeah i don't know the odds i don't know
the odds but i would give hooker a
slight edge
just anna's chandler's first fight in
the ufc i'm sure he has a lot of uh a
lot on his back a lot to prove
but i like his good point but like you
said he's a veteran he's been fighting
big names and stuff like that for a long
time so he might not even face him you
know
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be so
far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been